it's not how much you make it's how much
you keep and inside of this video i'm
going to share with you in a single
presentation everything that i have ever
learned in paying over 30 million
dollars in taxes in the last five years
which was miserable and probably paying
500 000 million in tax preparation stuff
so tax products experts accountants
audits all of that stuff all the fancy
things that the rich people don't want
you to know i'm sharing it all with you
here in this video it's a presentation
it's a little different than i normally
have so let me know if you guys kind of
like the longer form i know some of you
guys said you did and so if you're new
to the channel my name is alex mozy
welcome to mozy nation and enjoy and by
the way i have nothing to sell you after
paying 22.68 million dollars in taxes in
the past five years here's everything
that i've learned about saving taxes in
one presentation and if you don't know
who i am i'm gonna prove to you that
those numbers are legit in a second but
let's get forward and at the end of this
i'll give you my six consolidated
takeaways that you can immediately use
to save yourself taxes make more money
all that kind of good stuff and a bonus
set of beliefs that have served me well
up to this point in my life quick intro
my name is alex from rosie and my wife
and i own six portfolio companies that
do about 85 million dollars a year and i
have nothing to sell you if you're new
to mozi nation welcome
we own all of those into the portfolio
company of acquisition.com which is our
holding company and we just recently
sold a 66 taken two of those companies
at a 46.2 million valuation which you
can look up on the internets yourself
if you are skeptical which would be
totally realistic and reasonable of you
considering the many tubers and interweb
urs that exist that are probably saying
things that are a little bit stretched
from the truth all right so let's dive
in so quick confession um i used to be
obsessed with tax savings so it was
literally like took up a very large
percentage of my time
i spent roughly 1.6 million in legal and
accounting fees to figure out the
structure that i have today
and so this will be a culmination of all
my applied knowledge and beliefs related
to taxes to date as a u.s citizen
in a single presentation and hopefully
save you five years of learning and all
the money that i have spent so enjoy my
gift to you all right so here's the four
beliefs about taxes that have improved
my life and probably made me a lot of
money up to this point so number one is
that tax shelters cost more than they
save you might be like how is that even
possible great question i will dive into
it number two tax shelters decrease your
net worth how is that even possible as
well balderdash alex i know it's crazy
number three tax shelters diminish your
life
how can it diminish my life i will prove
it to you in just a moment number four
tax realtors don't make you a better
person you're like well that one i
believed okay fair enough well i'll show
you each one of these and more
so the problem with number one which is
tax shelters coffee more than they save
is that what tax shelters save you they
cost you more in other resources so what
they save you in money they cost you
more in other things alright so there's
three primary costs that people do not
account for and that i myself did not
account for when i started this journey
so long ago in the business world number
one is the cost of discovery and
conversion number two is the cost of
upkeep and number three is the cost of
unwinding and if you're like i don't
know what any of those things mean let
me explain all right so number one the
cost of discovery is that 90 i'm going
to borrow this from charlie monger so 95
of solutions are swampland and 5 are
legit and so as he is my hero
in many ways not just in investing um i
turned to him first to try and figure
out what the best kind of course of
action around tax was the short and
simple answer is pay them and the reason
for that is his quote here is that
19 out of 20 of these things are not
legit and are actually going to get you
into trouble and so the problem is the
cost of discovery is the is the the cost
of the time and the attention that it
takes you to sift through all the crap
to figure out the one out of 20 that is
actually worth it right and let's just
assume somehow you're like you know what
you did all of that work you got on
calls with accountants and lawyers and
your legal operating structure with
every one of these things and you ran
through all the tests that i'm going to
show you later in this slide deck of the
things that you should look for in these
types of structures and let's assume you
did all that stuff
then it you have this huge cost of
conversion right it takes a lot of time
to vet these things create new entities
transfer all your stuff over
reincorporate recreate your new
contracts for all of your clients etc
new banking relationships and all that
stuff so there's a cost of figuring out
which of these is actually legit which
95 of them are not number two is if you
actually happen to find something that
might be legit right not even including
the cost on the 19 that didn't actually
you know we're not actually legit then
you have the cost of converting them but
that's just cost number one cost number
two is that okay now you've converted
your thing
you have the cost of upkeep all right so
what you have to do now is you have to
trade valuable attention for less
valuable money by percentage all right
so i'll give you a couple stories to
drive this point home so a very close
friend of mine um
traveled 104 days a year back and forth
between puerto rico and the united
states so basically every weekend he'd
fly back home
and then you know on monday he'd fly
back out and he did this every single
day because he didn't want to pay us
taxes right but guess what he was
traveling 104 days a year and we were on
the phone and i was like hey man
do you think it'd be possible that you
could make 30 more money if you didn't
travel 104 days a year hmm
he was like i didn't really think about
it like that i was like yeah but you
should and the thing is so we're trading
this very valuable time and attention
for less valuable money by percentage
all right number two is i i have
a different friend who uh counts his
days in new york city to go back and
forth and it's like guys like can we can
we not figure out a way to to just make
more money within the current vehicle a
different friend of mine actually missed
their baby's birth
because they had to get their days in
right
like what are we trading here
and then finally
on a more tactical level a close
relative of mine uh was like hey i think
you should do this captive insurance
thing with me and i said okay let's look
into it so we looked into it together
and i'd already looked at captives a
couple times because you know there were
some tax savings by the way they're very
marginal in my opinion
and definitely not the
b cost of upkeep and so every month
every quarter you have to allocate a
certain percentage of funds and decide
how much of those funds you need to
allocate into the insurance vehicles so
that you can stay legit in terms of are
we really using this for insurance are
we gonna actually take claims out of it
and then what is a reasonable amount
that we can put in here and you're
constantly allocating attention to this
thing that does not provide value to the
business number two and this is what i
did not know when i was getting into
this game is that one there was the cost
of discovery and cost of conversion two
you've got the cost of upkeep and three
and here's the real one that no one
tells you about especially the people
who are trying to sell you these tax
shelters is the cost of unwinding and
fines all right and so not only do they
cost more than they save up front they
often don't even end up saving you
anything in the long run and here's why
most of the big tips and tricks get
unwound in a matter of years and the
reason for that is because the irs is
three to five years behind and so when
they see a loophole
they close it right but they close it
three to five years later because
they're so understaffed and all that
kind of stuff right and so often people
will get fined
because they uh they're evading taxes
right and so they'll say you were not
using this clause for the manner in
which it was intended so now you owe us
taxes on three years ago plus fines plus
interest
and so then you not only have the fines
in the interest but then you have to
spend the cost of the legal and the
accounting and all the other stuff to
unwind the structure that you did under
the wrong guys because you pretended to
use a structure in this way as it was
intended but you didn't actually do it
in the way it was intended because you
did it to save taxes which is not the
point of the clause and i have had this
happen to people i know very close to me
right and the thing is is like everyone
has to understand this
they write the rules and so what matters
most is what your intention is when you
use these structures that are complex
like the tax code is an incentive system
you have to think about it like that
they are putting penalties and
incentives so that they can move the
economy in the way that they believe is
right so the reason real estate has a
lot of tax incentives is because they
believe that they want people to
reinvest in infrastructure in the
company they want people to develop land
they want people to keep buildings from
falling apart and so they give lots of
incentives to people
to go invest in those things if all of
the tax incentives in real estate
disappeared real estate would not be
nearly as attractive and a lot of
buildings would fall into disarray
because it wouldn't be worth it to
people so then the country by extension
will vote to disrespect right and so the
idea here is that we have to read the
tax hood as an incentive plan
and that's just side note number one but
point is is that with these things they
cost more to discover cost more to
convert cost more to upkeep and most of
the times will not actually end up
saving you money in the long run which
is why tax shelters cost more than they
save okay so that was number one
hopefully we checked that box off number
two tax soldiers do not increase your
net worth and you're like how is that
even possible i thought the whole point
of this is that they're gonna increase
your net worth i will show you why so
what they save they cost you more and
other resources i'm gonna drive this one
in all right so there's three pieces
here one is the people two is the
thinking process and three is how
fortunes are actually built and number c
you're going to want to pay attention
because it's something that i did not
understand until way too late in my
entrepreneurial career so let's dive in
all right so the people so look at the
richest people in the world a lot of
them live in the united states and not
only that a lot of them live in
california and new york which is wild
right how is it the richest people in
the world can live in the highest tax
tax places in arguably the world how is
that even possible
maybe they know something that we don't
which is that they're using they they
know how to build fortunes which i'll
get to in point c but the thing is is
that
if that were the case then simply going
to a tax friendly area is not in and of
itself is going to increase your net
worth all right which i think is
important and is as an important side
note is that when you also surround
yourself with people in those types of
environments especially when people move
to very specific geographics only and
solely for the purpose of tax sheltering
right what in my opinion what happens is
they start thinking increments rather
than in orders of magnitude
so let me explain so it's majoring in
the miners it's thinking how can i save
30 percent chunks rather than make 30
times more money
right and you've talked to those people
they're going to make the argument like
well i know i'm going to do both it's
like no you're not because you're
literally sacrificing everything that
you have to just save 30
when and i'll get to the big picture
stuff in a minute but
the big wins are what drive your net
worth right so you can spend all this
time and attention obsessing about stuff
right these little doodads to save two
percent and one percent whatever that
might end up getting unwound up later
and because it's probably swampland it's
probably not legit anyways or you could
just bought bitcoin in 2014 and been
done with it the point is that the big
wins the very few big wins are the
things that are gonna drive the net
worth the most
not the tax shelters and so people
disproportionately allocate their
attention towards these savings when
that is not where the disproportionate
amount of the net worth is going to come
from so don't surround yourself with
people who are obsessed with this stuff
because they're thinking in increments
not in orders of magnitude they're not
thinking how can i 10x they're thinking
how can i save 10 and that in my opinion
is the wrong way to go about building a
fortune which if you're watching this
channel and you're part of mosination
that is the point all right so see how
fortunes are actually made uh this one
is one that i hope that you like slow
down and i will try to talk a little bit
more slowly than this because i really
want everyone to to get this one okay
so how forwards interaction made you
make and i grabbed this from jack
butcher f i think on twitter but this is
a loose loose uh
paraphrasing but you make fortunes by
taking a lot of risk with a little bit
of money you maintain fortunes by taking
small amounts of risk with a lot of
money all right so just understanding
how fortunes are actually made right now
let's dive into some some math in a
second so wealth comes from the
appreciation of equities not income all
right so how is it that all these very
wealthy people live in these high-tech
places it's because 94 of the force 100
growth came from appreciation not income
in other words
what we build builds our net worth not
what we make
huh
interesting let's dive a little further
into this all right
so let's let's let's put an example like
you're in year four of your business and
so let's say last year your business
made 10 million dollars in ebitda all
right which is profit fancy word for
profit sort of all right now and you can
move the zeros you can make it a million
you've made a hundred thousand it
doesn't really matter all right you make
100 million the point is let's just say
in this case
last year bison made 10 million dollars
in ebay our profit all right and let's
say
you it's valued at 5x which should be a
50 million dollar business okay and you
receive
10 million times 0.63 um which should be
37 is taken out for taxes you get
60 6.3 million in after tax dividends
and let's assume that you're not
reinvesting any of it in the business
and you're taking all those dividends
just for the sake of this simple example
okay now you're like okay i guess that
makes sense now pause and hold that so
you made 6.3 million and your business
is worth 50. got it now next year let's
say you go from 10 million to 12 million
indiabeta awesome good for you a little
20 growth very conservative sounds good
still valued at 5x and the value wait a
second goes from 50 million to 60
million huh but wait there's more you
receive 12 million times 0.63 which is
7.6 million dollars after tax in
dividends and so if you look at your net
worth increase the net worth increase is
10 million dollars
plus
7.6 million so you had a net worth
increase of 17.6 million so let me break
this down for you all right which is 60
million the new value of the business
minus 50 million right is the 10
and then 12 million times the 37 tax
rate gets you 7.6 you add the 10 plus
7.6 to 17.6 million but here's where
it's interesting if your net tax
so you made 22 million dollars in
increased net worth and your after tax
was 17.6 million then you were
effectively taxed at 21
huh and why is that it is because 56
of your net worth increase was tax-free
it was based on the appreciation of the
equities of the things that you own
rather than the income that you make
which is why what you build builds your
net worth more than what you make all
right so this one i really want to drive
this home if you can make the business
that you have more valuable the income
that you derive from the business is not
the primary value that you are actually
building right if you double the profit
of the business and you have a 5x
multiple right you are you have a double
multiplier that is happening on
something that you own in a very real
way compared to what you were actually
taking out of the business and so in a
lot of ways like give yourself the
salary live on the salary that you have
from the business but let the value of
the business compound and it doesn't
even matter if you're living in the
highest tax state ever because here's
what's even crazier this is valued at 5x
right if you look at publicly traded
companies like some of the s p right now
is traded at 40 which is absolute
insanity i'm not going to get into that
but that means that if i were to
increase
my ebitda in this example by 2 million
dollars there's a 40x multiplier which
means i increased my net worth by 80
million dollars
so
that is why these guys can manufacture
these fortunes because there's massive
multiplier on equities right so it's not
the income that you make that's the
thing that's building your net worth and
so letting that be the primary driver of
why you make your decisions and where
you live when how you feel about where
you live is going to create far more
wealth than the savings will right it's
orders of magnitude not incremental
thinking all right which is why tax
shelters do not increase your net worth
as much as people will make it seem all
right so number three is that tax
shelters do not improve your life all
right so
a little shift here is that i call this
inverted priority so saving the tax
money will hurt other aspects of your
life so let me explain so uh
one follow this line of reasoning i want
to increase my net worth so that i can
live where i want to live with the
people that i care about so in order to
do that i'm going to not live where i
want to live or spend time with the
people that i care about to have more
net worth so that i can wait a second
something doesn't make sense here and
that is correct it does not make sense
because what we're doing is we're
putting the means of achieving the goal
above the goal itself right and this
happens all the time because us as
entrepreneurs we create this this
reinforcing cycle of conditional
behavior we get this intermittent
resource which is how you create
addiction right of the work that we do
and we forget why we started doing the
work which is we have this goal don't
get me wrong
i think that work is the goal right but
at the end of the day if if we claim
that we want to uh increase our net
worth so that we can have this level of
freedom etc then we can't make the means
which is money
be more important than the things so for
sacrificing the goal in order to get
more means it doesn't make sense which
brings me to number two is why sacrifice
a resource that i care about and that i
can get no more of for one that i need
no more of and can generate at will
and as a side note has decreasing
marginal utility which means that the
more of it you have the less valuable it
is which is not the same with time but
anyways so number three um we can say
and this is actually a text exchange
that i had with a different friend of
mine
um
who you know i was like listen you know
we can be on instagram we can be on on
youtube and we can say money doesn't
matter and blah blah blah
but
it's a very different thing to say that
money doesn't matter or we can live that
money doesn't matter which means it's
like if you can be making these posts
and making these claims about how you
know you've really moved on from this
and you've got this bigger picture about
life and perspective it's like but all
you're doing is sacrificing your life
so that you can save little points here
and little points there it's like it's
fake it's not true like you don't
actually believe that right and so i
think there's one thing to be taught to
talk the path and another thing to walk
the path and so if we claim as
entrepreneurs
to want this freedom then i i hope to
god we don't we don't we don't flip the
priorities and uh and sacrifice our
freedom to get more means
and so i had a i had this was actually a
real conversation which was sparked this
entire presentation um is that it's hard
to do the whole temporary argument so
he's you know he was like what if i just
go there for a temporary period of time
stack enough cash then i'll come back
it's like the problem is that the enough
number is going to change and it's very
very hard to come back from paying zero
percent you know to paying a third or
half of your net worth and tax or half
your income and tax it's just hard
mentally i'm not saying like you can
still do the rational argument for why
you're doing it but it's just like i
think it's very hard emotionally to do
it and the thing is is that if we are
hard driving entrepreneurs which we are
we set up these games and move the goal
posts on ourselves and so you know i i
can promise you like my first freedom
number was four million dollars in after
tax net worth and then i immediately and
literally when we had four i was like oh
i think 10 is actually more reasonable
and then 10 went to 14 i have no idea
what 14 was really like meaningful to me
but it was and then from 14 it went to
20 and then 20 went to 30 because that's
what ultra high net worth is and then it
continues like okay now it's 100. and
the thing is is the goal post continues
to change because you become a cus you
you literally get exposed to higher
levels of wealth and then
what you say is like okay well this
this this level of wealth allows me to
live
but i want to thrive and then when
you're thriving then it's like well i
want to super thrive and why can't i
have an island in every single continent
that belongs to me right the thing is
you might and you might be listening to
this and be like i would never do that
watch your tongue
because a lot of very smart people have
said the same thing and experienced the
same desire because we
as hard driving people
play to win
and to stay hungry you move the goal
post but in moving the gold coast you
create a very difficult equation for
yourself to be satisfied all right and
so as a quick story to this um i could
have done and this is why tax shelters
diminish your life i could have done an
intentionally defective grand tour trust
which is a fancy thing that basically
functions like a waterfall of trusts
where um for every five million dollars
of a sale that you're going to receive
you out you put it into a trust and the
reason it's 5 million is because that's
below the the limit
and you have to wait three years before
you can touch the money because that's
after the trust passes the statute of
limitations on trust being unwound by
the irs you're like wow alex how do you
know this because i've looked into this
stuff right and i could have saved
myself about six million dollars in
taxes right roughly if i had done this
right i think it would have been more
than that but whatever roughly
but for what right to save more money
that i don't need and now to needlessly
give myself something to worry about
because i can't touch the money and i
have to follow these stipulations and
for some reason something happens then i
have the irs on my back and then
get audited right and that that little
story that i told you earlier about the
the captive uh that relative of mine
they ended up getting audited and even
if they do win
what a headache just to save like four
percent like who cares
right just go and make that much more
money without having the stress of a
darn audit and if they do lose now
they're literally gonna have lost all
the all the discovery time all the
upkeep time all the conversion time all
the the the effort that goes into it
they'll have to pay the fines and then
they'll have to pay the cost of
unwanting the darn thing right and all
of the attention that all of that took
they could have been spending on
increasing the value of the thing that
actually compounds tax-free
which is their business
crazy all right
okay
so i didn't do the intentional grantor
trust and i just paid the darn taxes
which brings me to point number four
which is that tax shelters don't make
you a better person all right so i only
have two main points on this and i will
i will drive these these home because i
think these are like as as we've gone
down these points uh they become
increasingly meaningful for me of
actually how i make decisions and so
these are the only two things that i've
really made the decision with which is
number one is reputational risk i
believe that i will be a billionaire at
some point before i die at this point we
have about 100 million net worth so my
wife and i
and uh we're you know i'm 32 she's 29
and so
like if i if we just get 10 a year like
we will hit it and that's if we don't
make any income and we don't grow
businesses which that would drive me
nuts and so we will be doing that so i
think that at some point we will do that
but who knows by then maybe billionaires
everybody will be a billionaire and an
apple will cost a million bucks who
knows but the point is is that um i
would never want to become a billionaire
and then have everyone say he did it
and escaped taxes i just don't want that
brand i'm not saying there's nothing
wrong with that like i don't think
there's actually anything wrong with
that if you did it legally right um but
i would just prefer to be known as the
person who paid his dues and still
killed it that's just me that's a
personal preference that's a
reputational risk for me right and i've
said this quote before this channel but
i'll say it again like you only get one
name
and you have to keep it for the rest of
your life right and so it's like
investing in accordingly i can't imagine
like that at that point in my life if i
were you know worth 2 billion or 3
billion and i could have been worth
remember guys like if you're saving 30
right on your taxes it's only going to
increase your net worth by that
percentage
like think about it so it's like if
you're worth 10 million and you had
saved 30 of your taxes you'd only be
worth
30 more than that so it'd be like 13
million right like and just think about
it like that it's like
so it's not like this crazy like it's
just that that's all it is right so
number one is reputational risk and for
me i don't think i would ever sacrifice
my reputation for that marginal gain all
right number two
85 year old self test and this is my
number one most tweeted tweet which is
when i was 20 i wanted to be a
millionaire now that i'm a millionaire i
want to be 20. and i overheard a version
of this which makes me realize that when
i'm 40
i'd rather just be 32 my age with
nothing just to be 32 again which is a
different frame on gratitude that i
thought i'd share which brings me to my
85 year old self test which by the way
is probably the most useful decision
making frame i've ever made and it's
probably the thing that i use the most
in thinking through everything in my
life all right and so when i think about
my 85 year old
deca billionaire whatever and he's old
and crass is hell and he's looking at 32
year old self alex he laughs at me at
the idea of sacrificing anything for
money sacrificing my youth to make more
money that i won't need
like i would give half of my net worth
back to live my life wherever i wanted
to during my youth and to make 12 more
net worth if you're deciding between
states like will i care if i have 9
billion or you know or or 11 billion or
9 billion or 6 billion when i die no
i won't and so i feel like i can
envision this conversation that i have
with myself it's like don't don't
sacrifice anything for me like i'm good
i'm old like you're young
enjoy ever like just soak in life
because it's going to go away fast
and like most of the things that you're
concerned about won't matter and you
will always have more than enough and
you'll never go hungry and you'll always
have people around you who love you and
so like
just live
and so this idea of obsessing over these
shekels that we're going to give back at
the end of our life just seems silly to
me and that's at least why my 85 year
old self laughs at me for thinking about
these things rather than just spending
time in the places that i want with the
people that i love all right which
brings me why number four is that tax
shelfers don't make you a better person
all right so so far we covered number
one tax shelters cost more than they
save number two tax shelters don't
increase your net worth number three tax
holders don't improve your life and
number four tax shelters don't make you
a better person all right and so if
you're mosey nation you're like okay
well what do i take from all this i'm
gonna give you six rules of thumb which
is why i added an extra finger onto that
palm and then seven beliefs that have
served me well i told you i'm gonna make
one presentation to rule all others for
myself and you so that i can also
partially make this as an answer to a
question that i had which is what do you
do for taxes so this is it all right so
if you're not going to listen to any of
the advice that i said up to this point
and just pay your taxes which by the way
i'd like to thank our special sponsor
the irs
for sponsoring this video uh six rules
of thumb for you all right so let's dive
in real tax savings typically come from
three primary scenarios number one is
when you give up ownership or control
that's what charitable giving is right
that's why trusts tend to be vehicles
that people will use because if you do
them correctly you no longer own the
money which is why you don't owe the
taxes on it right that's the idea all
right so you either have to give up
ownership or control typically to do
that and so some people when they really
see it they're like oh like so this
isn't my money anymore it's like yeah
now you can make the argument like well
you control it cause you control the
person blah blah blah but the thing is
is like there's a lot of steps there um
and it's up to you but like that is like
when the real saving stuff comes from
things like that number two
is that they come from depreciation so
in the tax code just like i mentioned
earlier with real estate like the
government wants like the tax code is
just an incentive plan right it's it's
the government's way of saying we want
you to do this and not do this right and
so they allow you to depreciate assets
that you're buying uh which allows you
to not pay taxes because they basically
function as losses right so if i buy a
building for 10 million dollars i might
be able to depreciate 4 million of that
building and if i had made 4 million
dollars that year then i could
depreciate and have zero tax which by
the way is how most people who run real
estate funds do it is they don't give a
lot of the depreciation of the people
who are investing and they as the
general partners will take a
disproportionate amount of the
depreciation from a company from the
funds that they raise so that they can
pay no money which is how grant cardone
doesn't pay taxes right that's the idea
that's how he does through depreciation
all right number three is deferral over
elimination all right and so this is
also just a rule of thumb is that like
a lot of these structures allow you to
defer the taxes rather than eliminate
them and so the idea is you basically
defer them until you die but you're not
necessarily eliminating them so the
three ways at least that i have seen
that have have been the most legitimate
um across times et cetera is are these
concepts all right
um
that being said here's some of the
advice i have for you
in almost all of these structures there
is hair you must find it make sure it's
really worth it factor in the cost of
discovery factor in the cost is
conversion factor in the cost of upkeep
in a savings cost factor in the fee
structure that they're going to impose
upon you to do this whole thing right
and whenever you hear someone say the
wealthy you've been doing this forever
it's just a sales pitch when they're
like ah like the vanderbilts have been
doing the structure for a hundred years
like it's every single guy says that so
just like just move on get over it right
but you have to factor in the money the
time and the intentions it cost you and
it and could you allocate that into your
business get a much higher return
something to think about right
number three don't pretend to know
things that you don't know don't be
afraid to ask questions seriously anyone
who makes you feel otherwise is not to
be trusted all right i always start and
this is a very true every single person
my company would know this especially my
finance team like when we hop on calls
with like experts and all this stuff i
always say the same thing i say hey i
just want you to pretend you're
explaining the structure to a golden
retriever all right who speaks spanish
all right pictures simple words i want
to understand and if someone cannot
explain something to you simply it's
either because they're trying to confuse
you or they it's because they do not
understand it fully
think about that
people if you are confused and someone
cannot explain something simply to you
it is because either they do not
understand it or just because it's their
desire to confuse you and seem
intelligent neither of those scenarios
are good for you so if they kind of
cannot explain it to you visually and
simply
i would say look run the other way all
right because either they don't have the
right intentions or they don't have the
right skill level of skill all right
so number four this is one now you're
like okay i checked all the other boxes
now always ask for people who've been
doing this strategy for over a decade
and asked to speak with them the reason
for that is because the irs will unwind
things three to five years after they
impose a clause because they'll find out
that people are using it as a loophole
in order to get through and evade taxes
all right and so what they'll do is
that's why you need to look at people
who've been doing this for over a decade
because they've already gone through a
full irs cycle and you can say okay
you've been doing this for 11 years
you've never had any audits you've never
had any issues okay great
let me talk to three other people
because you might have just been lucky
let me talk to you know a handful of
people and see what was the cost of
upkeep what was the cost of conversion
or how much time per month you have to
allocate to making sure that this
continues to stay you know within the
standards of the irs and then and then
is it worth it right
number five
always do background check on the person
and the entities that the owner
associate with quick story on this one i
had a recent person say hey i think this
thing's really legit i think it checks
all the boxes blah blah and so i looked
into it which is not something i
normally do because i've kind of like
made up my mind on this which is i just
pay my taxes but that being said i
decided to look into this one and
literally on the first google search i
had of the guy who owned the entity all
right there's two there's two red flags
right off the bat number one is that the
entity was a brand new entity which
means that they're spinning up new
entities uh all the time that is a big
easy red flag of like why don't you have
the same entity why are you trying to
always change etsy's all the time that
seems weird there's no reviews online
etc okay
second
is
if and after i googled this person they
had literally been indicted
for tax evasion
and i was like what
and like one of the biggest tax of
ancient scandals in history right
and uh and you know the guy made the
intro was like but they got to quit it
and i'm like do you want the
reputational risk of being associated
with someone like that right and if
someone someone might be like hey alex
can't believe you forgive he was proven
like i get it
there's just other people who haven't
and for me i would rather just not take
the risk that's just my two cents all
right so always do a background check on
the people and the entities this that
they own and are associated with all
right and then finally
don't spend money on stuff that you
wouldn't just to expense it all right
this is one that i hear all the times
like just expense at expensive right i'm
saving x percentage on this like if you
if you spend money that you otherwise
wouldn't in order to save money because
you don't have to pay taxes on the money
it's cutting off your nose despite your
face right
like it's like oh i don't want to pay 30
of 100 or 40 of 100
so i'm just gonna not even have a
hundred dollars right that just doesn't
make a lot of sense to me now if you
were going to do it then by all means
like if you want to reinvest in the
business and that that's expensible then
great then wonderful as long as it's the
asset and here's the key point it's like
if we can if we can if we can figure out
a way that it can become an asset that's
going to build value within the company
and somehow it's expensible then
fantastic right that's the idea uh but
spending money on stuff that uh that you
wouldn't otherwise just to not pay taxes
is a very very very silly way of living
life in my opinion and ultimately not
one that is a good behavior that will
build wealth over time all right so
these are just my six rules of thumb
that if you're not going to listen to
the advice at least please do these
things when you're thinking through some
of these other tax structures that you
come with and then finally these are the
beliefs that i currently hold um i'm not
saying you have to hold these but these
are the things that have served me very
well all right
so number one is that attention is my
number one most valuable asset never do
anything that takes it without
disproportionate return number two pay
zero attention to tax savings teams
focus on the making not the saving
number three whenever it decides to come
up
right number three
there we go replace savings with orders
of magnitude so instead of trying to
think in increments thinking orders of
magnets instead of saving ten percent
think about how can i 10x and then
you'll never have to worry about the
taxes again number four never count your
pennies on roads untaken all right it'll
destroy your spirit and have you focus
on the wrong part of your life your past
versus the future so if you make one of
the decisions to start living the place
you want to live or live in a state that
you that you feel like being in whatever
right don't start thinking i could have
saved 12 over the last four years have i
had that money right now like don't do
that it'll destroy your life and
probably you might not have made that
money that you made now because you
would not have been in this head space
that you are currently etc right at the
end of the day there's just there's no
benefit to it so once you make the
decision move on all right number five
this one and this is this is a big one
all right
just remember that when i die and this
is me right remembering that when i die
the people that i compare myself to will
also be dead
right and here's a crazy one we will all
be taxed at 100 as in we don't get to
keep it no matter what
and so here's my here's the probably the
best analogy that i can give you which
is a casino analogy and this is this is
kind of how i imagine
really life in the game overall right
which is that
i believe all of us are given a token in
the in the casino of life right and we
walk in the door and we sit down to the
table and there's a bunch of other
players around and we can and we get
dealt cards and we play the cards that
we're dealt right and depending on our
skill uh in the game we can continue to
amass and amass chips right and we get
these stacks and stacks and stacks of
chips but the difference between a
regular casino and the casino of life is
in the regular casino you can take these
big chicks go to the counter
cash out take your cash celebrate etc
and then you get to go spend that money
but in the casino of life
you have this big stack of chips and
then when the grim reaper taps you on
the shoulder and says you can't play
anymore you have to get up from table
and the chips stay on the table and what
they do is they push them right to the
middle of the table and everyone keeps
playing with your chips
and so for me when i think about it it's
like do i just want to be in a nice
casino or a shitty casino but at the end
of the day
i have to give all the chips back
and so for me when i think about it like
that it's like no matter what happens
i'm getting taxed 100 upon death and you
might be like oh legacy it's uh to me
that's silly because sure multiply by a
hundred generations of people who don't
know you change their last names and
have mixed their their genetics with you
you know uh one half to the hundredth
power and no they're they're just humans
and no they don't remember you and no
they're not your your descendants
they're just humans and so all of that
stuff goes away with time and so it's
like we're just here to play the game
and all of the chips that we amassed are
going to get put back in the middle
anyways and why sacrifice the lighting
and the niceness and the types of people
that i get to play the game with so that
i can potentially keep a higher
percentage chips again the table that
i'm only going to give back at the end
something to think about
and then finally money exists to buy us
options therefore do not trade
optionality for it
all right so um
if you are new to this channel thank you
um i make these videos because no one
helped me learn this stuff i had to
learn the stuff on my own or to pay a
lot of money for these lessons either in
mistakes or in experts and advice and so
i hope that the pain that i experienced
isn't in vain which is why i make these
videos i just hope that someone can
benefit from it and i like this visual
here because we have these goals we fail
we learn principles we improve and then
we have more audacious goals and my goal
for you guys is that you can just jump
from audacious goals to more audacious
goals because you can just use the
lessons that someone else has already
learned and suffered the pain
of consequence for all right i repurpose
that from ray dalio's principles but i
just really like that visual and so um
anyways welcome to moseynation if you're
new appreciate you enjoy the video
hopefully some of these takeaways can be
helpful in your journey along taxes and
entrepreneurship love you and i'll see
you next vid